talk to me about coverage what on earth
is uh going on more than 40 000 cases a
day why is there such a slow uptake of
the vaccine boosted i think that's
something that we really need to address
uh kay and as you know it's open to
everybody over the age of 50 and also
vulnerable people and i would urge
people who can
uh to take the booster jab because the
vaccination rollout has been the most
successful
thing we've done
and it's allowed the economy to open up
and as we opened up as we hit the uh
fourth phase on in july it was it was
clear that you know we had to live with
uh the virus and it was likely as we
opened up that there would be more more
cases now the critical thing as my
colleague the health secretary has said
is about hospitalization and also
uh deaths and and thank god those
figures are much much lower than they
were certainly at the beginning of the
year although still going out 223 deaths
yesterday it's a situation that we're
concerned about
but you'll remember the beginning of the
year we had uh
hundreds if not thousands a day
um but mercifully that hasn't happened
and as the secretary the health
secretary said it's something we're
going to have to live with and i think
we are managing the situation he went
further than that didn't he he said um
he said it was going to be a
particularly tough winter how worried
about you uh how worried are you i
should say about the um nhs being
overwhelmed i think winter's always
difficult as you know because there are
lots of things
uh going around lots of viruses and it's
a particularly vulnerable time for lots
of elderly people and people uh in our
country and also
for the health service
i think with coronavirus it does add an
extra complication
but we're confident
that with the vaccine rollouts with the
extra booster
jab take up the situation is can be can
be managed well okay let me let me take
you back to um older people not wanting
this vaccine booster now
you may remember i worked in a in a
vaccine hub um at the start of the year
and one of the concerns was a lot of
older people came in and if it was
a fisa booster if it was a pfizer
inoculation they didn't want it they
didn't want pfizer they wanted
astrazeneca if you've had astrazeneca
you're now mixing it with pfizer and how
are you going to convince them that that
is the right way forward and if not
would you consider bringing back azad
i think we just have to push the message
and
certainly at the beginning of the whole
vaccination process
there were groups of people that were
quite reluctant
uh to take up uh the vaccination
some older people were particularly
people from ethnic minorities but we
actually did a good job
in encouraging people who were reluctant
uh to take up the vaccination and that's
what i think we will be doing certainly
uh to drive up how are you going to make
that happen because it's not working at
the moment well i think i think it can
work i think people uh need to continue
what are we talking about we need to we
need to get the communication out there
and that's what we're we're doing and
that's what plan b
uh i'm sure will it will involve um and
we we need to get people more awareness
uh more uh
people more comfortable uh with the
difference between
seneca will you bring that
i think for now we want to stick to the
fighter and get the booster jab
campaign up and running and that's what
we're focusing on what's going to be the
paint look like well it's just
communication making sure that people
understand that the vaccination rollout
is key
to protecting themselves and their
families and that's something that we
can keep people like me on shows like
this
can can keep pushing that message but
you have said that's what plan b would
involve so obviously it's and other
things and i mean you mentioned them you
mentioned the other issues what about
these walk-in centers because um the
walk-in centers are virtually empty is
what we're being told anecdotally
because people are being told they
shouldn't go to have a jab until they're
called up by the nhs that's mixed
messaging no
let me be very clear about this i think
that people who are eligible for a
booster particularly people over the age
of 50 other vulnerable groups should be
uh taking up the booster jab because
that's and that's clearly the best way
that's clearly the best way to protect
themselves and also their families and
people they care about
and the wider community sure of course
that's why we all have vaccinations
isn't it um 12 to 15 year olds um
90 of them are unvaccinated why is that
not working 200 000 children off school
last week with covert i think i think it
is working but we just need a faster
rollout i mean it's easy to say that
things aren't working when they've just
started or we need to we need to push
them on for weeks so we need to push
them more uh uh you know dynamically but
it but it is working you acknowledge
that it's not been pushed dynamically
enough at this stage well i'm saying
that we could always do better we can
always improve okay you know that uh we
nothing is ever going to be you know
perfect but we can be more um dynamic in
pushing it and that's what i would urge
people to do because 10 uptick's not
enough is that no um we need to we need
to to increase that okay uh plan b we've
been talking about uh plan b um
let me just ask you about sorry i forgot
about lateral flows are they going to
continue to be free um i think so um i
hope so but uh let's let's see what
happens because they weren't going to be
were they they were going to start
charging for them we weren't going to
give them away if people rang the nhs or
or went on to the app and ordered them
it was no longer going to be free but i
was reading in the paper this morning
that that's a bit of a u-turn overnight
is that your understanding well i i i
i'm assuming that it'll continue to be
free but i don't know what the precise
detail is on that okay
plan b uh now hearing about plan b plus
um do you know what that might be
looking at suggestions that there could
be restrictions on holidays again no i
don't think so look i think the the
conversation about restrictions on
travel restrictions on you know more
lockdowns is completely unhelpful i
think we've
had a huge job of work getting the
vaccine rolled out to the point that we
could reopen the economy that was the
main thing we were focused on this year
that has worked and what we want to do
is manage uh the the situation as it is
we don't want to go back into lockdown
or into further restrictions did say
that this time last year though
well last year we we didn't have a
vaccine this time last year we didn't
have a vaccine
the vaccine has changed
our total approach to this and has given
us a measure of security which everyone
is enjoying and that's why we've managed
to open up these as long as people take
up the boosters yeah no i would say that
repeatedly i mean people should that is
very important okay um stephen reicher
who as you know is a member of sage
is advocating plan c and saying that we
can't rule out another lockdown no i i
would rule that out
um clearly
throughout this process
there have been people saying
the lockdown was unnecessary and have
been other people saying we should
continue the lockdown we've really
plotted a path between those two
extremes i think it's worked and that's
why k one of the reasons we've got the
fastest growing economy in the g7 it's
7.5 this year that's the prediction
which is faster than any other
comparable country certainly in the g7
and there's a reason for that and that's
because we've managed to successfully
roll out the vaccine and reopen the
economy and that's something that i
think we're i'm very grateful for okay
let's just hammer home the point before
we go on to energy people watching um
this morning getting the kids ready or
half term or whatever it might be you'll
be finding yourself in that position
before you know it trust me um
you need to take up your booster the
kids need to be vaccinated
in order for us not to go back to where
we were this time last year
i think that's absolutely of a fair
um a fair message i think we should just
keep rolling out
the vaccination i mean that's what's
given us the security and the safety
that we've we enjoy at the moment and
you think we're going to have to have
those boosters every year
i don't know look i mean you know
we we have flu that comes back uh
regularly um it may well be that covid
is is in that in that category
all i'm focused on is this year and
making sure that enough people
uh get the boosters enough people are
double vaccinated because still not
everybody is uh double vaccinated um so
that we can give protection in the here
and now what happens next year and the
year after
uh is something that um you know we will
have to just wait and see exactly okay
talk to me about um the energy plan that
we heard about yesterday artemara has
been uh reading it um she missed
succession last night so that she could
read the document and um brief me up on
it
it's certainly genuinely world-leading
um but a lot of people with old drafty
houses and diesel cars are going to be
saying how much is this going to cost me
i think that's a fair question but if
you actually look at
what the strategy says
and what it's trying to do
is that it's trying to actually attract
huge amounts of private investment
into the uk and what happens with
private investment is that the unit cost
of the energy actually is driven down
it's lower it's it's cheaper
and this is what happened with offshore
wind i mean if you look at back
even in 2012 40 percent of our
electricity came from burning coal today
that's about one between one and two
percent
and the big difference has been uh
renewables and if we look back over the
last nine years the cost of those
renewables has gone down hugely
something like two-thirds so more
investment actually in diverse energy
sources is actually going to reduce
costs in the medium and long-term and i
think that's good our homes there's not
these heat pumps are not going to work
are they well the heat pumps uh we've
got uh boiler upgrade grants we've got
huge incentives for people uh to make uh
that transition
and also we're we're making sure that
new build houses
um have a higher standard of energy
efficiency
than older houses there's still issues
with retrofit we've had
various schemes and we're looking at
schemes uh now to encourage people and
also to incentivize um making sure that
our homes are more energy efficient
shouldn't the government be saying from
today any new house that is any new home
that is built in the uk should have a
heat pump we're not having gas boilers
in new homes anymore so there are a
range of sources of of energy uh supply
heat pumps are a great source we want to
increase that there are things called
heat networks if you live in apartments
and i've seen them in in london
particularly
and they're going to be
more widely adopted so yes heat pumps
are absolutely uh central but there are
other forms of
carbonation there's gas boilers should
not be being put into houses that are
being built from today yeah i mean we've
said that the gas boiler will be will be
phased out
why do that why not just say because as
you say it's it's it's very costly i
mean what we don't want to do i mean
it's a fine line you have to tread
between making the transition
and essentially forcing people
and posing costs on people
uh to make the transition and what we
want to do is to keep people uh with us
on the transition on the journey yeah um
just to take you back to insulating
homes so you know my hou my home is old
and draughty and because of where i live
i can't do anything with the windows et
cetera so they're it it is very
challenging for some people i'm sure i'm
not the only person there'll be lots of
people watching this morning in a
similar position it is challenging i
mean we've been we've gone through these
transitions and people forget this but
you know when we went from town gas to
natural gas that was a huge uh
nationwide drive over many years
and the town gas was was filthy stuff
and we managed to transition to natural
gas and this is
another transition we're saying that
we can actually have a more a cleaner
more sustainable
environment and most people want to see
that
i'm always struck by the numbers of
people young people in particular that
are very infused uh by this and they
really want us to to get going and as
usual people are saying some people are
saying it's it's too expensive and we're
moving too quickly a lot of other people
are saying we're not moving fast enough
and that's an important debate to have
in a democracy i'm talking about how
much um it's going to cost to uh power
industry uh given the increase in
energy prices um obviously you sort of
seem to get
get across purposes with um the treasury
over that a couple of weeks ago
and they were saying that you were
basically making things up i don't know
where that came from must have made you
very cross i'd have been very cross if
people were telling me i was telling
porkys um you know i speak to the
chancellor we speak together you would
expect people responsible people
watching this program would expect
government departments to be talking to
each other and that's exactly what we do
i don't know where that remark
particular remark well i do because it
was somebody from the treasury who spoke
to our deputy um
deputy political educator
and they said he's just making it up i
don't know anything about that um
trust me i'm not lying to you that's
what that may be what happened but then
you'll remember about that you will
remember kay uh you know we said that we
we speak to each other all the time
uh the prime minister number 10 said uh
we speak to as you would expect you
expect the secretary of state for the
business to be speaking to the
chancellor and the team's relevant teams
to be talking and that's what i do which
is why i can't understand that they
would say something like that it's just
divisive but maybe you should ask them
yeah and but because you're here i'm
asking you
no i just want to say that we have a
very good relations i'm going to speak
to the chancellor and yesterday um i saw
him a cabinet and uh he congratulated me
on the birth of my child so well i'm
sure he's relations are very cordial i'm
sure it certainly is uh with him so
you're just rising above any nonsense
that we well i don't know where these
comments come from uh they're not
helpful they're much more diplomatic
than they were they're not true either
we talk all the time okay it's good to
see you and congratulations thank you on
the birth of your little girl what's her
name ida ida lovely thank you very much
for joining us thank you